[Music]
on this saturday night truckers roll
into ottawa hauling their anti-vaccine
mandate message
[Music]
let us free
let us free end these mandates fringe
groups catch a ride on the convoy
concerns about safety put the prime
minister on the move and pushing back
against putin nato's next move to avoid
all-out war
and wicked weather hits the eastern
seaboard this is one of the worst storms
i've seen so far how the supply chain
crunch is making it harder to dig out
[Music]
global national
reporting tonight
chris
[Music]
the trucker convoy has arrived in ottawa
parliament hill is filled with thousands
of protesters yes truckers who oppose
government vaccine mandates but also
many others who have much different
agendas the demonstration is expected to
last all weekend but some are vowing not
to leave until all public health
restrictions are lifted good evening and
thanks very much for joining us the
protest underway and our nation's
capital is loud and proud but so far
authorities say it has been peaceful our
chief political correspondent david
aiken has been covering the convoy all
day and has the latest on the
demonstration there david
chris there's a reason all these
protesters came here to parliament hill
it's because this is where the
politicians work whose rules they don't
like
[Music]
so far over two days it's been noisy but
peaceful and while protesters have many
different grievances the common
denominator is the desire to be rid of
vaccine mandates it's all mandates it's
for the freedom of everybody here
that's why i'm here and i'm going to
stay as long as it takes to change
everything
in fact convoy organizers say they'll
stay put clogging up parliament hill
until the federal government changes the
rule requiring international truckers to
be vaccinated they might be waiting a
while the federal government refuses to
change vaccine mandates for its own
employees and those working in a
federally regulated sector we then went
on to implement it in the transportation
sector but we gave truckers more time
to get vaccinated the opposition leader
aaron o'toole met with some truck
drivers friday according to this tweet
though his office has refused to answer
calls or emails to explain who he talked
to or what he said but while o'toole
avoided the spotlight saturday many
conservative mps like these two from
alberta were in the thick of it i'm just
here to listen to the voices of
canadians who are peacefully assembling
by and large but while the conservatives
stand with the truckers many of these
protesters well they stand with maxine
bernier leader of the people's party of
canada i hope that the traditional
politicians will understand that you
know
we must reopen the economy we must stop
all these mandates as for municipal
politicians ottawa's mayor jim watson
was upset at this several protest
vehicles including an rv parked
overnight on the cenotaph at the
national war memorial some would leave
some were towed by ottawa police and
watson later said that parking on what
he called the sacred ground of the tomb
of the unknown soldier was a sign of
complete disrespect
watson and others also slammed the
protesters for desecrating the terry fox
monument on parliament hill also today
the canadian trucking alliance issued a
statement saying to canadians that those
you may see and hear this weekend here
many of them are not connected to the
trucking industry and the alliance also
says to canadians that the vast majority
of their members their truckers are like
most canadians fully vaccinated chris
david aiken in ottawa thanks david now
smaller protests were also held across
the country in solidarity with those in
ottawa
[Music]
a slow rolling convoy formed in british
columbia's fraser valley eventually
making its way to vancouver's downtown
core in alberta rcmp issued several
travel advisories as large
demonstrations there disrupted a number
of highways in the southern part of the
province and protesters also gathered
outside the manitoba legislature in
winnipeg
the protest in ottawa forced the
cancellation of a vigil to mark the
fifth anniversary of the quebec city
mosque shooting on this day in 2017 a
lone gunman opened fire on worshipers
inside the islamic cultural center six
people were killed and more than a dozen
others were injured members of the
muslim community had planned an
in-person vigil today at the human
rights monument in ottawa but they say
threats of violence coming from some of
the convoys attendees forced them to
cancel the live event
i'm frustrated and i'm angry this uh
protest that's going on it's been
labeled a freedom protest well no you
know what no it's not a freedom protest
because my freedom the freedom of all
those who are gathering uh going to
gather tonight get together our freedom
has been taken away to gather peacefully
the group will instead hold a virtual
vigil to remember those killed in the
attack
it's been nearly two years since covet
19 was declared a pandemic daily
confirmed cases remain at record high
levels in some jurisdictions but there
are signs infections may have peaked
nationally and that has many canadians
wondering when we might get back to
normal new ipsos polling done
exclusively for global news shows
roughly one in five people feel things
are normal now and about the same number
say they're not sure they'll ever be
ready to live without masks or vaccine
mandates 64 percent say they believe
governments aren't doing enough to get
us back to normal but according to ipso
ceo darrell bricker they can't agree on
what politicians should be doing
this is the controversy coming back into
things and things are not as certain as
they once were around this pandemic and
the management of us what we're running
into now is a whole bunch of questions
about how we're going to be moving into
the next phase of however we're going to
be dealing with this
but bricker says those surveyed are
united on one thing and that's keeping
the health care system safe 81 percent
believe that has to be our top priority
the white house is closely watching
russia's military buildup along
ukraine's borders u.s president joe
biden says a small number of american
troops will be sent into eastern europe
to counter rising fears of a full-scale
russian invasion
i'll be moving the u.s and europe and
the nato countries in the near-term
russian troops are now lined along
ukraine's border in belarus for
so-called military drills belarus's
strong-arm leader alexander lukashenko
says there will be war if there are any
signs of aggression towards his troops
or russian forces the pentagon says u.s
troops are on standby for deployment to
support nato allies
canada has committed non-lethal support
to ukraine mostly in the form of
training ukrainian forces but some
critics say that's not enough and
question whether diplomacy has a real
chance of success this week on the west
block eric sorenson speaks with
ukraine's former ambassador to canada so
eric what did he have to say
chris the ambassador made it clear
ukraine wants more help and it wants it
now and that includes weapons canada has
agreed to extend its training mission in
ukraine for three years and to add 60
more troops to continue to train
ukrainian soldiers plus ottawa is
offering non-lethal equipment
we do have some mixed feelings here
ukraine's former ambassador to canada
andrey shevchenko told global's the west
block that his country appreciates
canada's help but would have liked
weapons such as anti-tank guns
when it comes to the weapons it is one
of the most powerful signals of
deterrence towards russia and we do need
them now not when the aggression
escalates further
putin kremlin his generals and the
russian soldiers have clearly have to
clearly realize the consequences of
their moves as russian troops continue
to build along the ukrainian border
shivchenko says russia's vladimir putin
is trying to blackmail the west to get
what he wants which is a guarantee that
ukraine will not join nato it seems to
be more sort of a psychological warfare
as of the moment it can turn very
physical very brutal and militarily
catastrophic in no time
and it's extremely dangerous the risk he
says is not just a ukraine but to global
security along with andrey shevchenko we
will have on the west block sunday
morning omar algabra the federal
transport minister who will talk about
the disruption in ottawa this weekend
from the truck convoy and other
protesters chris look forward to the
program thanks very much eric sorenson
in ottawa a powerful winter storm is
sweeping through the maritimes
blanketing provinces in snow most of the
region came to a standstill today with
police warning people to stay home and
avoid treacherous driving conditions
flights ferries and bus routes all saw
cancellations across the board
environment canada says some areas could
get up to 40 centimeters of snow coastal
areas are expected to get several hours
of freezing rain now that same system
spawned an historic blizzard bearing
down on the northeastern u.s with the
possibility of up to 60 centimeters or
more of snow in some areas high winds
and heavy surf are forcing many people
to leave their homes governors have
declared states of emergency in at least
five states and officials are warning
wind chills will be dangerous jennifer
johnson reports
from the mid-atlantic to new england
millions of americans woke up to
blinding blizzard conditions snow is
falling at record rates and winds have
been clocked at more than 130 kilometers
per hour in many coastal towns residents
have been told to get out as hurricane
four storm surges cause widespread
flooding
this is one of the worst storms i've
seen so far the wicked winter storm is
hitting 10 states pummeling some of the
country's biggest cities including
philadelphia new york and boston
airlines have canceled more than 4 500
flights amtrak suspended or limited rail
service on the busy boston to washington
corridor i'm going to say it again
to the fullest extent possible stay off
the roads
several states ordered all vehicles
except essential personnel and first
responders off the roads heavy trucks
have been banned from numerous highways
adding to the concerns more snow plows
than operators in several areas as kobe
19 keeps many drivers sick at home
and supply chain issues have caused a
severe shortage of snow blowers normally
i get somewhere between 90 and 110 units
and this year i got 11.
and that's all production problem
widespread power outages are being
reported tens of thousands already in
the dark in massachusetts
the good news this massive storm came on
a weekend with few commuters on the
roads and schools closed but not
everyone thought that was a bonus it
could have came during the week when i
had to work
that would have been better for me it
would have been a snow day
with pay despite the dangers of this
powerful storm many new englanders are
taking it in stride going to build a
snowman i'm going to throw snowballs at
people it's going to be great classic
fun i'm excited but first responders are
more concerned asking millions to take
precautions as this latest nor'easter
takes a vicious winter whack at
america's east coast
jennifer johnson global news washington
still ahead cracking the long covid code
what researchers are learning that could
help clear up infections sooner and you
don't know what you got till it's gone
why you won't find joni mitchell's music
on spotify anymore
[Music]
canadian music legend joni mitchell is
removing all of her music from spotify
in a message to fans mitchell says she's
standing with neil young who demanded
his songs be pulled from the streaming
giant in protest of joe rogan's podcast
young accuses rogan of spreading covet
19 misinformation and refused to share a
platform with the comedian and
commentator rogan's podcast is by far
the most popular on spotify
well researchers are continuing to
unravel the mystery that is long covered
a condition impacting hundreds of
thousands of canadians while there is
still a lot we don't know
a pair of new studies is shedding new
light on the neurological symptoms many
long haulers are experiencing heather
yorick's west reports
when heather jane first began
experiencing symptoms of long covid she
had no idea what was wrong my acute
phase of covid was in the very early
first wave april 2020
and so
you know
for me it was really hard to understand
what was happening to my body it's
estimated that more than one-third of
covid19 sufferers will report continued
symptoms like fatigue or breathing
problems for months after their initial
infection has resolved and now
researchers out of australia are
beginning to better understand who has
been impacted we found
when we looked at the blood and as well
as
immune cells within these participants
that there was a dysfunction
within the
immunological pathways the discovery of
a biomarker within a patient's blood
could not only help develop a better
tool to diagnose the illness but could
lead to better treatments as well while
researchers still don't know what causes
long covet a leading theory is that
parts of the virus can linger in the
body causing inflammation triggered by a
prolonged immune system response and
according to another recent study that
inflammation can cause neurological
symptoms for up to nine months young
people who survived through cover 19
despite the fact that they might didn't
have any symptom or have the only mild
symptom
months later they still had
a very
mild impaired impairment in memory and
attention while there is still much to
learn about this condition that for some
can be debilitating heather jane is
trying to maintain hope i'm a very
different person now and i've been
forever changed by this experience two
years after her first infection the
toronto woman is now recovering from
covid yet again
unsure of how this second round will
impact her long-term health heather urex
west global news calgary
coming up it's one of the most pristine
marine ecosystems on earth why the
weddell sea off antarctica is under
threat and worth saving
[Music]
a state of emergency has been declared
in an area of thailand after an oil
slick washed up on a stretch of beach
near ray yong about two hours south of
bangkok it's estimated between to 50
tons of oil leaked tuesday night in the
gulf of thailand from an underwater hose
used to load tankers the leak was
stopped within hours but oil hit local
beaches today there are fears this will
decimate the local tourism industry
already struggling to recover from the
pandemic
scientists are calling for protection
for a barely understood part of the
world a piece of antarctica called the
weddle sea it sits at the top of the
continent southeast of argentina
scientists say making it a marine
protected area would shield it not just
from climate change but from human
threats and as ross lord reports experts
say there's not much time left
at a time when climate change is making
waters in the antarctic warmer and
rearranging ocean currents the wittle
sea has been mostly immune it's an area
that's going to have hopefully a more or
less intact ecosystem for much longer
than we're going to have in other parts
of the antarctic more time for penguins
and other species to adapt to whatever
changes they eventually encounter
but researchers and conservationists say
marine animals need protection from
other threats like large-scale fishing
they're pushing for the weddell sea to
be declared a marine protected area
governments have failed for several
years to create an ocean sanctuary in
the world of sea this cannot be another
year of delay
and continued harm to penguin
populations and other wildlife here in
the antarctic
marine protected areas are becoming
widespread by some estimates almost
eight percent of the ocean is under some
sort of protection including 14
locations in canada at 2.8 million
square kilometers the weddell sea would
be the largest marine protected area on
earth but holdouts including china and
russia are reluctant to give up their
fishing interests as the political
wrangling continues so does research
like determining how penguin populations
are holding up in the current
environment we need to do science on the
ground first that's why we're in a place
like this a penguin colony to understand
change and what's here already so that
we can protect the species where they
need it most bolstering their argument
for conservation fully aware that what
ultimately happens in the weddell sea is
out of their hands
ross lord global news
next finding refuge in play time afghan
refugees get out of quarantine and have
some fun exploring their new home
[Music]
that is ash barty celebrating big after
serving up success on home soil ending a
44 year long grand slam drought the 25
year old became the first aussie to win
the australian open since christine
o'neill captured the women's singles
title back in 1978
and she did it without losing a single
set
this is just a dream come true for me
and i'm i'm so proud to be in aussie so
thank you so much everyone
the women's world number one recovered
from being 5-1 down in the second set to
beat danielle collins 6-3 7-6 barty now
has three grand slam titles under her
belt
[Applause]
how about that indeed the greatest
quarterback to ever play the game is
apparently calling it a career the nfl
confirms 44 year old tom brady is
expected to retire after 22 seasons and
seven super bowls including last year's
victory in his first season in tampa bay
he came back to attempt a repeat but
tampa got bounced from the playoffs
brady leaves the game holding records in
super bowl victories passing touchdowns
and several other categories
well since arriving in canada some young
refugees had a chance to run and have
some fun with other children during a
field trip to explore their new home as
global's dan grumman reports the
children are finding refuge in play time
kids typically love field trips this one
is sorely needed i can tell you they
were really excited they saw the bus
pull up and they thought they were going
to school
no school not yet instead this visit is
more like recess play time that's eluded
these kids most of their lives they've
been living
under a lot of anxiety a lot of tension
a lot of danger they are afghan refugees
and along with their parents fled their
home country last year to escape the
taliban takeover they were in hiding
until finally coming to canada two weeks
ago since arriving in edmonton they've
been quarantining in a hotel the hotel
facilities are wonderful for a place to
sleep and a place to eat but it's not
really set up for a place to play this
week it was finally time for some fun
catholic social services which is
helping resettle 170 afghan refugees in
edmonton partnered with a local youth
sport organization to access the space
for the more than 60 kids they don't
have a lot of structure in their lives
and so this is a great opportunity for
kids to come here play for these parents
to be able to have their kids come here
in a safe place to be able to play for
the first time in months if not years
is just something you can't put a value
on it's just a couple of hours of sport
but it epitomizes why their parents
risked their lives to come here for the
freedom to act their age
grumman global news
awesome and that is global national for
this saturday night i'm chris galas
tonight your canada is a shot of shoe
swap lake from salmon arm bc we'd love
to see your corner of the country so
please keep sending those photos to
viewers at globalnational.com
thank you very much for watching i'll
see you back here tomorrow hope you have
a great night
[Music]
you